if it's too hard to shower today
grab the baby wipes
it may not be the normal way to do it
but you deserve to be clean
if it's too hard to cook dinner
get paper plates heat up something
Frozen you'll go back to cooking and
washing another day but the day is not
today and in the meantime you deserve to
eat if you're too depressed to do your
dishes get a two gallon Ziploc bag and
keep it in your bedroom because if you
put a dirty plate into a two gallon
Ziploc bag and seal it it will keep the
bugs away
because you deserve a sanitary
environment even if you can't get out of
bed
I could share with you hundreds of other
genius solutions that people have come
up with once they embrace the idea that
care tasks are morally neutral
in my experience people will exhibit
mind-blowing creativity
when they are only taught how to speak
compassionately to themselves